Cobra Kai's backward belongs back on top
but the real story is only just but I
thought you were dead Cobra Kai never
dies
ever since the tournament all I've been
thinking about our ways to destroy Cobra
Kai but opening your own dojo make sure
you can balance up balance is my thing
we got some new recruits it's just been
same karate cult
it's brainwashing half the school that's
why I'm opening up Miyagi does room for
one more
someday the fight may come to you and I
want to make sure you're ready that's
you
Sammy see what Miyagi dough is made of
something tells me there's a can of wax
in my future it's okay
which one of you has the balls to take
on the chimp Miguel sorry what a lie
you better hope that your soldiers -
ready in pigs do you have a crush is it
Robbie the fight is only over when you
say it is let's finish the fight a sense
they doesn't take destruction and
disrespect we need to talk well what you
can put in my kids heads aimless since I
taught you to strike first strike hard
no mercy
these things don't end well
this isn't a tournament away there are
no rules
it's not an idea to fight
you want to finish this right bring it
on
you